Developing this morning, Ukraine
security service has launched
a war crimes investigation
into the horrifying video
that appears to show the beheadi
of Ukrainian soldier.
This is the second video to emer
on social media showing graphic
violence against Ukrainian soldi
CNN is not showing these videos,
but we do have some freeze frame
from the clips
that appear to show the victims
and the perpetrators
and give us a sense of who they
Let's look at some of that.
You can see the white leg band
that indicates support
for the Russian military.
The person appears to be kneelin
to a body on the ground.
Additional stills says
CNN has not yet released
show the yellow armband worn
by Ukraine's military.
Ukrainian President Zelensky
vowed to hold those behind
the videos accountable
Yet this unicorn was
reaching the Muslim world in Rwa
There are things
nobody in the world can ignore.
How easily these animals murder.
What kind of creatures are they?
They don't care about a human be
A son, a brother, a husband,
someone's child.
This video shows
Russia trying to make it a new n
All right.
CNN's Ben Wedeman is in eastern
for us.
Ben, as we said,
there is now a Ukrainian
war crimes investigation.
What is actually known about the
that are now out there
Well, frankly,
CNN cannot verify the location.
There are two videos that appear
on Russia's
pro-Russian social media channel
The first
appears to be shot
at this time of year
and purportedly in the area of B
involving soldiers
of the private military company,
the Viognier,
a group what you see in that vid
is the
beheaded corpses
of two Ukrainian soldiers
next to a destroyed military veh
It also appears
that their hands were severed as
Now, on that video,
you can hear a voice say
they killed them.
Someone came up to them,
they came up to them,
and cut their heads off.
In the second video,
which appears to be perhaps
shot in a different season, it l
this summer, it's somewhat blurr
But what you do see is a soldier
cutting the head off
of a Ukrainian soldier.
And from the sound of it,
it appears that the Ukrainian so
was alive as this was going on.
And as you pointed out,
there has been shock and outrage
among Ukrainians at the site of
video.
In fact,
the defense ministry is asking p
to stop sharing this video.
On social media as soon as possi
John,
it's barbaric.
Again, the
veracity of it at this point
can't be confirmed,
but it is simply barbaric.
What are the Russians
saying about it, Ben?
Well, Dmitry Peskov,
the Kremlin's chief
spokesman,
has said that the video is terri
but that the authenticity
has yet to be proven now.
Yevgeny Prigozhin, the head of t
group, says that he sees no indi
that his fighters were involved.
But we know in the past
there have been videos
of similar atrocities.
There have been videos or videos
of Russian soldiers
killing in cold blood
Ukrainian troops who had surrend
So such
atrocities are not unknown
in this war, John.
Yeah. Again, barbaric and horrif
Ben Needham in in eastern Ukrain
thank you so much for your repor
Please stay safe.